on va passer à l'anti portrait chinois
si vous étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi
ou qui j'espère que je ne serai pas
l'envi mais peut-être l'envié vous étiez
une injure
tabernacle c'est une injure que j'ai
entendu au québec et maintenant comme on
dit ça fait chier partout et même à la
télévision j'ai décidé de dire taberna
c'est dur les chanteurs québécois murat
peux vous en parler
s'ils tiennent accident la chute à vélo
j'aime bien faire du vélo mais peut-être
que je n'ai pas une forme olympique et
j'aime bien les descendre car je fais du
vélo
michel drucker ici voilà il ya plus de
celle ci vous étiez une perversion
l'amour conjugal une guerre la guerre
des nerfs
un vice la lecture quotidienne de
l'équipe
c'est vrai service vis à vis avant les
intellos souvent si ça non mais moi ça
et ces essais c'est cet ancien m'a fait
aimer le vin et voilà et les sionistes
les jours ouais c'est une trahison à bas
ce serait la trahison des idéaux de ma
jeunesse généreuse grégaire et un peu
débile ouais c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
je pars remettre de l'huile sur le feu
mais vous pensez que c'est dépassé ça
non je pense qu'il faut essayer de
réfléchir autrement je parlais tout à
l'heure d'un coeur intelligent c'est une
expression je n'ai pas inventé paraît-il
c'est l'expression du roi salomon et en
arène que reprend à son compte
donc il s'agit pas d'opposer l'émotion à
la raison mais il s'agit d'être dans
l'émotion à la hauteur de la singularité
des événements si vous étiez une arme
le pistolet à eau vous étiez un supplice
l'écriture une cicatrice c'est dur or je
sais pas peut-être une très longue ligne
de la main ouais ça peut toujours servir
je tiens un poison l'insomnie un impôt
assis gt1 impôts je ne taxerai le bruit
à mort une portable le bruit le bruit
comme si vous étiez une panne
une panne d'inspiration un dictateur
alors si j'étais un dictateur je
désinventer les portables et
j'interdirais la musique d'ambiance
ah bon ah oui la musique d'ambiance dans
les restaurants dans les cafés face à
l'heure dans la gare est dans les temps
les magasins et r1 la musique contre la
musique d'ambiance c'est une infirmité
peut-être justement une certaine surdité
à la musique
je ne suis ni pas été éduqué dans la
musique donc je suis un peu sourd et je
le regrette beaucoup
c'est un microbe staphylocoque doré ah
oui c'est chiba oui je dois avoir levé
le coude avec judith y ait une plaie oui
c'est une vraie toujours une torture
la page blanche une humiliation
j'essaierai de pas trop la ramener
si vous étiez un terroriste le
changement de métier c'est gallimard